there are so many people who say that
human nature is savage that if we can
rid ourselves of social constraints we
would become animals and literally eat
each other alive but I don't know if
that's necessarily the case I think they
are there are sides of us that are quite
brutal and quite selfish but nature has
given us many gifts among them something
called the helpers hi the neurobiology
of helping others literally acts of
compassion acts of kindness when we
submit when we volunteer by our own
volition to serve other people to extend
our hands towards one another we get a
biological reward our brain literally
rewards a sick creats pleasure chemicals
it drugs us into bliss to reward us for
being kind to one another I mean you
guys understand what I'm talking about
our fundamental wiring is there to give
us a prize right to give us a reward to
be kind and collaborative and
cooperative with one another this is
known as the helpers hi it's what people
say that nothing gives them as much
satisfaction as helping other people now
it makes sense from an evolutionary
standpoint that we would have inherited
this biochemical reward for working and
collaborating with other people because
we take care of our tribe and we're more
likely to survive by working together
all good the science is there I love it
but it's the metaphysical dimension that
really turns me on it's turning through
this wiring during moments of despair
when we think the world is going to hell
when we fear that what is out of sight
is out of mind and we feel that the
world perhaps lacks compassion me
watching the media this day certainly
makes you feel that way and I guess what
I'm saying is that it's during these
moments that we might turn to this
awareness to this notion that no my
friends that a fundamental nature is
good that a fundamental wiring is set up
in a way to give us gifts to shower us
with blessings for being kind to one
another at the risk of repeating myself
I guess what I'm saying is it is its own
reward do not seek external payment
trust in the inner satisfaction that you
will get by offering your life to some
higher purpose find the need that's
lacking in the world and turn your
passion into a purpose and I don't know
I mean that's the kind of thing that
certainly makes me willing to get up in
the morning to believe that that by
making a fundamental difference in
someone else's life
I'm also getting off and that's not a
bad thing